i think it's a little early to judge how
it's being viewed both
internally in ethiopia and uh in the
international community
i think it is a success uh qualified
success
for prime minister abi but with some
caveats and
that is the fact that about one-fifth of
the constituencies
did not participate in the election for
either
technical or other reasons you had a
boycott by
several key political parties and there
have been some 207
uh complaints about the election but
nevertheless there was a high voter
turnout
and uh it appears as is always totally
peaceful so the election of course
took place before the military defeat in
tigre
so we it had no impact upon the election
uh it remains to be seen
what people think about the problems
that
the government now faces in tigray that
may come back to haunt prime minister
abi
but in the meantime he can ride on his
laurels of an electoral victory
i think that his first priority has to
be what do you do about tigre
and how do you deal with the
humanitarian crisis that exists there
and if he handles that badly all of this
could
not go well for him internally in
ethiopia
there are other issues that he has to
grapple with he has a very full place
that he's going to have to resolve in
the coming months and
if he mishandles it he's going to be i
think in some difficulty
you